So rule number one, if a person is TH1 dominant, you can't use TH1 stimulators.
Both the line, matter of fact, I have not seen any line protocols out there that other TH1 stimulators protocols.
So both the line protocols out there are going to have TH1 stimulators in there.
They work really good if you're in the chronic phase.
So I didn't count it protocol, and it just cleared it up, but I told my sister to do it.
And she's just, you know, she's just been getting worse and worse and worse.
And now they think she has FX.
Really?
Well, because she's in the bottom of your face.
She can't be tanky that stuff.
You cannot use stimulators of the side on the immune system that's done it.
Number two, you have to kill the pathogen directly.
That's why law and turf antibiotic use works.
So if you're in law and turf talking a couple of years or five years antibiotic worse,
work of use, people have been healed by that.
The problem is it has so much destruction.
And just about kills the person before it gets a better.
But what are they going to do?
Well, they're talking about a few things that you could do.
There's other things from a nutraceutical standpoint that will work to kill the pathogen directly.
There are specific nutraceuticals, meaning when I say nutraceutical, that means that some supplement that you would tank in your body.
Does anybody heard of MS?
That's what that will work directly.
It doesn't stimulate the immune response.
It's lower acid in.
It's another one.
It's your proxide that kills pathogens directly.
There's ways to take that all that stuff down.
But those will stimulate a TH-1 response.
There's not a whole lot of choices from a nutraceutical standpoint.
And honestly, at least half of the line patients that we see, they can't take any of that either.
So, a literally half the line patients that we see are taking definitely from a nutraceutical standpoint.
Except things that won't stimulate an immune response, like vitamin D won't stimulate an immune response.
Good fats, maybe fish oils, other good oils won't stimulate an immune response.
So, those are nutraceuticals, but they're not taken to kill the line.
They're just taken to help build up the process by the B vitamins in order to stimulate liver function.
But that's not taken to kill the line.